est ce que vous pourriez être candidat
je me prépare je me prépare je suis très
bien ici au sénat et vous a pas échappé
que le cumul des mandats était
impossible entre un mandat parlementaire
les mots d'un exécutif local
encore faut-il qu'on soigne au plan
local naturellement moi je me prépare je
réfléchis tout ce qui intéresse ma ville
m'intéresse c'est vrai que beaucoup de
lillois viennent me voir spontanément de
différentes sensibilités en pensant que
voilà je suis quelqu'un de respecté de
respectables diront certains mais moi je
souhaite en parler bien sûr d'abord avec
la principale intéressée qui est martine
aubry se prépareront qui elle-même doit
se voit là doit se plaindre question
c'est martine aubry avait dit à mon
dernier mandat s'étend au delà il ya un
problème c'est un fauteuil pour deux
fautes pour personne ah il faut une
primaire qu un free présente dans le
sens où une élection n'est jamais gagnée
d avance et en tout cas ce que je sais
c'est que la division serait mortifère
mortifère et que donc c'est sur un
projet politique que nous devons nous
mettre d'accord moi même encore une fois
je réfléchis d'abord sur le projet et
nous verrons bien si je suis le mieux à
même de pouvoir le porter mais on ne
peut pas se faire entre guillemets dans
l'éviction des uns ou des autres ça va
se faire dans la concertation et je le
dis ici sur votre plateau si martine
aubry souhaite me rencontrer pour
évoquer ces questions pour préparer
l'avenir de l'île et surtout éviter que
cette baie froid si fort pour nous en
terme de symbole de bascule à droite ou
au centre droit emmené le département
comme le département et nous avons fait
beaucoup d'erreurs qui nous ont amenés
malheureusement par le départ vous avez
rappelé